so we've depicted here the area under
the curve f of X above the x-axis
between the points x equals a and x
equals B and we denote it as the
definite integral from A to B of f of X
DX now what I want to do in this video
is introduce a third value C that is in
between a and B and it could be equal to
a or it could be equal to B so let me
just introduce it right like just like
that and I could write that a is less
than or equal to C which is less than or
equal to B and what I want to think
about is how does this definite integral
relate to the definite integral from A
to C and the definite integral from C to
B so let's think through that so we have
the definite integral from A to C of f
of X actually we have already used that
purple color for the function itself so
we use green so we have the integral
from A to C of f of X DX and that of
course is going to that's going to
represent this area right over here from
A to C under the curve f of X above the
x-axis so that's that and then we could
have the integral from C to B of f of X
DX and that of course is going to
represent this area right over here well
the one thing that probably jumps out at
you is that the entire area from A to B
this entire area is just the sum of
these two smaller areas so this is just
equal to that Plus that over there and
once again you might say why is this
integration property useful that if I
found a C that is that is in this
interval that it's greater than or equal
to a and it's less than or equal to B
why is it useful to be able to break up
the integral this way well as you'll see
this is really useful it can be very
useful when you're doing discs when
you're looking at functions that have
discontinuities if they have step
functions you can break up the larger
integral into smaller integrals you'll
also see that this is useful when we
prove the fundamental theorem of
calculus so in general this is actually
a very
very very useful technique let me
actually draw an integral where it might
be very useful to to utilize that
property so if this is a this is B and
let's say the function I'm just going to
make it constant over an interval C it's
constant from there to there and then
it's and then it drops down from there
to there let's say the function look
like this
well you could say that the larger
integral which would be the area under
the curve it would be all of this let's
just say it's a gap right there or it
jumps down there so this entire area you
can break up into two you can break up
into two smaller areas so you could
break that up into that area right over
there and then this area right over you
here using this integral property